>> OKAY, THE MISS AMERICA BEAUTY
PAGEANT WILL NO LONGER BE A
BEAUTY PAGEANT.
IT WILL BE A COMPETITION.
THE ORGANIZATION ANNOUNCED TODAY
IN A STATEMENT, WE ARE NO LONGER
A PAGEANT.
MISS AMERICA WILL REPRESENT A
NEW GENERATION OF FEMALE LEADERS
FOCUSED ON SCHOLARSHIP, SOCIAL
IMPACT, TALENT AND EMPOWERMENT.
BUT THIS COMPETITION WILL NOT
INCLUDE THE SWIMSUIT COMPETITION
WITH THE ORGANIZATION STATING,"
WILL NO LONGER JUDGE OUR
CANDIDATES ON THEIR OUTWARD
PHYSICAL APPEARANCE.
WELL, LET'S DEBATE THIS.
MEDICINE, A FORMER MISS OHIO IN
THE MISS USA PAGEANT.
THIS IS WILD BECAUSE, IF,
MADISON, OUTWARD APPEARANCE HAS
NO RELEVANCE WHATSOEVER TO THIS
WHOLE THING, THEN WHY DON'T YOU
JUST DO IT LIKE, ON THE RADIO?
I HOST A RADIO SHOW AND A COLOR
MADE A COMMENT TODAY.
I WAS SCREAMING LAUGHING.
I WAS THINKING, YOU DON'T HAVE
TO DO THE MAKEUP OR THE HAIR,
YOU COULD JUST TALK.
>> THEY ARE EXACTLY RIGHT, I'M
NOT IMPRESSED WITH WHAT
MISS AMERICA ORGANIZATION HAS
DECIDED TO DO.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE DEFINITION
OF PAGEANT, IT IS A CONTEST.
OF COURSE OUTER BEAUTY IS NOT
THE SAME AS IN HER BEAUTY BUT IT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT OUTER BEAUTY
SHOULD NOT EXIST.
WOMEN SHOULD BE ABLE TO EXPRESS
THEMSELVES, HAVE A POSITIVE BODY
IMAGE AND TO SHOW OFF THEIR
PHYSICAL FITNESS.
THERE IS LITERALLY NOTHING LEFT.
EVENING GOWN CAN BE ANYTHING YOU
WANT.
IT CAN BE ANY OUTFIT.
SO, I DIDN'T KNOW THAT IT WAS IN
THE 90s THAT -- IT WAS WHEN
THE BIKINI STARTED.
SO IT WAS LIKE 97 I TNK THEY
STARTED DOING THE PEKINGESE,
WHICH YOU KNOW, BY MEN LIKE IT
BUT IT IS A LITTLE MUCH ON THE
BIKINI.
BUT THE ONE PIECE, I THOUGHT
THAT WAS PRETTY AND DIGNIFIED
AND ALSO AND ATTRACTIVE.
BUT, THIS, IS IT THE "ME TOO"
THING, LIKE DON'T HATE US?
>> I CAN'T EVEN KEEP UP WITH THE
FEMINIST PART.
THE FIRST THING EVERYTHING WAS
WOMEN SHOULD BE EMPOWERED AND BE
ABLE TO WEAR WHATEVER THEY WANT
AND NOW THEY ARE SAYING WOMEN
SHOULDN'T BE ABLE TO WEAR
WHATEVER THEY WANT.
I CAN'T KEEP UP, IT'S RIDICULOUS
AND TOTALLY OFF BASE.
I DON'T THINK THEY ARE MAKING A
POSITIVE IMPACT ON THE "ME TOO"
MOVEMENT.
>> AND THEY ARE CASTING
ASPERSIONS ON PEOPLE LIKE YOU.
NOW YOU WERE MISS OHIO, AND YOU
JUST TOOK THE BAR, PASS THE BAR,
CONGRATULATIONS.
SO MANY PEOPLE IN THESE PAGEANTS
AND COMPETITIONS GO ON TO DO
INCREDIBLE THINGS, MAYBE THEY
ARE PROFESSIONAL MOMS OR
DOCTORS, LAWYERS.
BUT JUST BECAUSE YOU ARE
ATTRACTIVE DOESN'T MEAN YOU ALSO
DON'T HAVE ALL THESE OTHER
THINGS YOU WANT TO DO IN LIFE.
>> EXACTLY.
IT SHOULD NEVER BE MUTUALLY
EXCLUSIVE AND THAT'S I THINK
WHAT THEY ARE TRYING TO MAKE IT.
>> IS THERE A REAL RIVALRY
BETWEEN THEM MISS AMERICA PEOPLE
AND THE USA PEOPLE?
>> THE JOKE HAS ALWAYS BEEN COME
MISS AMERICA IS THE GIRL NEXT
DOOR MS USA AS THE GIRL YOU WISH